I was going through a period in my own
career where I was struggling to trust
people
and didn't know who to trust and I know
trust is important everybody keeps
telling us trust is important but they
don't tell us what trust is or how it's
built simultaneously I just happen to be
spending time with folks in uniform with
folks in the military and I kept meeting
these people who would willingly risk
their lives to save the lives of people
they didn't even like whereas in
business you know we don't even want to
give up credit for things let alone Our
Lives I started asking the question how
do I get people like that at work
and my original theory was that they're
just better people and better people are
drawn to this life of service which is
fine why you find it disproportionately
high number of these high trusting High
sacrifice people and the more I started
to learn the more I started to
investigate the more I realized I was
completely wrong it's not actually about
the person it's about the environment uh
you can take a good person and put them
in a bad environment and they will do
bad things conversely you can take
someone who may have been perceived as
untrustworthy you can change their
environment and they can change their
lives and become valuable members of a
team and who's responsible for setting
the environment leaders leaders set the
environment so if you can create an
environment biologically trust will
follow the trust for me is a tricky one
when we put it on the wall as value
because we can't instruct people to
trust and values have to be things we do
I like when values are written as verbs
you know it's not innovate you can't
like walk into someone's office and say
please innovate you know but you can say
think of the problem differently you
know honesty you can't put honesty on
the wall it's tell the truth and trust
is one of those weird ones because trust
is a result you know you can't tell
people trust me it doesn't really work
that way in fact the least trustworthy
people are the ones who tell you that
they're the most trustworthy right um
what generates trust is when we actively
work to make others feel safe the result
is trust so trust is value though not
intellectually wrong it's very hard to
execute because you can't tell people to
trust it's not an instruction and I I'm
a great believer that as I said the best
values are are often written as actions
as verbs because you can tell people you
can do them you can hold people
accountable to them and you can even
measure them and build incentive
structures around them